hi everyone my name is april zang and
today i will be talking about my senior
research project
fellowship through the tea bioinfo
organization
so my project is called predicting coven
19 patient severity with machine
learning
so here is a brief overview of the
topics that i will be covering today
i'll touch on what inspired my project
to methodologies
and then finally wrap up with the
results of my project and with that
let's jump
right in
so last march our world changed in ways
that i couldn't even imagine
for the masks we're wearing right now to
curfews lockdowns practically everyone
has been affected by coven 19
in some way shape or form there is about
3.24 million deaths
in 155 million cases and these two
numbers are constantly growing
last summer my mom actually contracted
coven 19
but fortunately she only had mild
symptoms and recovered quickly
of course i was incredibly grateful but
extremely curious as to what exactly
distinguished my mom
from the millions of hospitalized
patients that were struggling
for each breath that i saw on tv so it
was this experience that
really prompted me to pursue this topic
as a senior research
project
okay so these probably look very
familiar to you guys
right everybody sitting here um probably
you know has done temperature checks or
been asked if they've experienced these
symptoms but
what differentiates these common
symptoms of mild cases
versus life-threatening lung injury that
many severe cova-19 patients face
so again here you can see sars-kova ii
has a few stages depending on the
disease severity
most about 80 percent of patients stay
within the mild to moderate illness
which you can see is that light blue
curve
whereas 20 of patients progress onto
severe illness this is where
ventilators are required or
hospitalization and even
acute respiratory distress syndrome
so again here you can see the end of
this diagram is a little bit complicated
but if we just focus
on the these little pink alveoli so the
alveoli
are the gas exchange sacs of the lungs
here you can see the difference between
healthy infected moderate and severe so
there is a buildup of fluid within
both the moderate and severe cases and
this is what
causes the gas exchange to become more
difficult hence
shortness of breath
okay so now that we know what the virus
causes between mild and severe cases
let's look at host immune response host
immune response is really important to
look at because
how the immune response reacts how the
immune system reacts will
ultimately determine disease severity
and there are of course many factors
that contribute to a patient's reaction
so in severe patients typically a
cytokine storm is common
this causes a widespread and detrimental
impact on multiple organs
loss of severe patients are also
characterized by a hyper inflammation
signature
high levels of neutrophils which are a
type of white blood cell that releases
cytokines which are responsible for the
inflammatory response
okay so having established that my
project objective
is to identify and investigate what
genes
that are responsible for the different
disease severities
so put simply i want to explore the
correlations between gene
expression and disease severity whether
that's a mild or severe covalent
cova 19 disease case and i did this via
machine learning
so the type of data that i chose to
analyze is rna sequencing data so using
rna-seq we can identify what proteins
are being transcribed
which tells us which genes are being
expressed upregulated or down regulated
in using this information i can
investigate the relationships between
gene expression and disease severity
so the output of rna sequencing is a
gene expression table
the data i downloaded from online was a
gigantic
gene expression table with over 19 000
rows
um jeans which were included
and then here you can see this image
describes the basic rna-seq workflow
and for my project i've worked mostly
with the bioinformatics
portion
okay so i obtained my data from
ncbi's publicly accessible database
one of my data selection criteria was to
have a data set with more than 100
samples
this is really important for machine
learning mostly because the algorithm
has more examples to build a
model off of which will improve the
model accuracy
and the data that i ended up choosing
was in transcripts per million and was
derived from
um tissue origin of leukocytes which is
just
the overarching term for all white blood
cells
here you can see this is an image of
some of some of the possible data sets
that i was investigating and i organized
them by
number of samples and other clinical
data that the
researchers may have provided for
example age sex etc
okay so after the data is collected it's
really important to normalize it
as many machine learning algorithms
assume a normally distributed data
so to do this i performed quantile
normalization with a threshold of five
i also performed a logarithmic
transformation
and eliminated any low expression data
which i did via python
so here this is just um a code block of
some python that i wrote this was for
transposing data files
so i actually originally tried to do
this with excel but the program
could not handle a table with over 19
000 rows so i ended up having to do that
in python
and then i also did eliminate any low
expression
data for example any genes that have
zero expression and over half the
samples those genes were eliminated
okay so the next step is the machine
learning portion which is kind of the
bulkier part of the project
so before i jump into this what is
machine learning
machine learning is a type of ai that
takes input data
and investigates the different patterns
between groups within a training data
set
and then we'll apply what is learned to
a test data set
this type of machine learning is known
as supervised machine learning
so this diagram is actually really
deceptive because there are many
intricate parts to machine learning for
instance optimizing your parameters
and before doing this project i had
never heard of these algorithms before
right
random forest svm and naive bayes so
with no previous experience this was one
of the challenges that i had to
overcome throughout this project and
then i
accessed all of these pipelines all
these machine learning algorithms via
the t
bioinfo platform where they have it all
nicely set up
okay so the final step of my project
is to put what i found in a biological
context
so using david which is an annotation
tool
i was able to functionally annotate the
14 genes that my algorithm
that my algorithm had selected and
i'll talk a little bit about how i got
these 14 genes later
i also conducted a thorough literature
review investigating the role
of a few of these 14 genes in kova 19
based on previous findings
okay so here is a table of the different
machine learning algorithm
trials that i ran so you can see they're
grouped by mean decreased
accuracy cutoff abbreviated as mda
the training model and then the test
data classification
training model and test data
classification accuracy excuse me
so mean decreased accuracy basically
represents how important a gene
is to accurately um classifying a set of
data
so for instance if i were to take out a
gene
that had a higher positive mean decrease
accuracy for instance
3.7 then that
the model accuracy would decrease
by that number 3.7 percent
whereas if i were to remove any data
that had
negative mean decrease accuracies that
would improve the classification
accuracy of the
algorithm and so i focused on
this 1.7 mean decreased accuracy cut off
with the
svm algorithm because this trial
had a reasonable balance between the
training model accuracy
which was 95.12 and also minimum number
of features
and usually with machine learning we
want to identify
the minimum number of gene features that
can still accurately classify between
groups in this case mild versus severe
so this is why i
ended up using this trial run
so out of the genes that i'd selected i
investigated
two of them and found them to be linked
in dizzy severity and i'll go more in
depth
for a few of these genes in the next
slides as well but here you can see this
is just a brief snapshot of all the
14 genes that i found
okay so the first gene i investigated
was ccr5 which is a chemokine receptor
protein it's located on the surface of
white blood cells
so previous findings have shown that the
ccr5 expression is significantly
upregulated in sars cova 19
infected cells so if we were to put it
the opposite way that means if we
inhibited this
gene expression in severe cova-19
patients
this would help to reduce inflammatory
cytokines
and decrease the sars covalent to rna in
plasma
so in simple terms identifying this gene
and its role in aiding cova-19 infection
this allows us to intervene and possibly
inhibit ccr5 expression and help
control disease severity so this could
be
a possible therapeutic target to help
treat severe infections
okay so the next gene that i looked at
was h6pd
which is a enzyme that's really
important to reducing
oxidative stress and preventing cell
destruction
so past findings have shown that this
g6pd deficiency
affects about 10 percent of
african-american males so
again in simple terms having a g6pd
enzyme deficiency
may put african-american populations at
a higher risk for developing severe
symptoms due to cover 19. and of course
this may be a plausible explanation
as to why african american populations
seem to be harder hit by cover 19
with higher death rates three to six
times higher compared to other races
so you're probably wondering why is this
research important
this is useful because in the future we
can do a simple
patient blood draw and then run an
rna-seq analysis to see what genes are
upregulated or down regulated and then
for instance some of the genes i
discussed before could possibly serve as
predictors for severe or mild covalent t
and disease severity
so in turn this can really help doctors
know what to expect
and more effectively treat patients in
the future
and then with that i'd like to give a
big thank you to
my on-site advisors dr mr
chione ms sternfield and then my
off-site advisor dr corp
for their invaluable mentorship and
guidance throughout
my research project